امتثال تويتر لمعايير الخصوصيه يزيد
السجاله في الكونغرس الامريكيه حيث يتساءل
مشرعون حول ما اذا كانت المنصه تحت اشراف
ايلون ماسك قد انتهكت قوانين حمايه
المستهلك وبياناته بعد عمليات تسريح
واستقالات واسعه ما قد يعرضها مع صاحبها
لمخاطر قانونيه هائله اربعه اعضاء
ديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ هم اليزابيث
عبروا عن قلقهم بشان امتثال تويتر
بالتزامات لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه اثر
رحيل الرئيس السابق لقسم الثقه والامان
منه واعتبروا ان سلوك ماسك يكشف لا مبالاه
واضحه تجاه التزامات المنصه القانونيه وهو
مصدر قلق حسب ما صرح لنا السيناتور
الديمقراطي تمكين
مقارنه مع ما فعلوه بالقوانين التي
ينتهكونها يجب توضيح ما يحدث ان محبط حقا
من جوده القياده التي قدمها ماسك لهذه
المنصه التي يستخدمها الجميع وكما تعلم
اعتقد انه سيرغب في ان تكون منصه موثوقه
لكن بدلا من ذلك يجعل الامر اقل ثقه به كل
يوم من الواضح انه مصدر قلق تويتر يخضع
حاليا لتحقيق من قبل لجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه بشان انتهاكات محتمله مرتبطه
بعدم تطبيقه سياسات امن بيانات فعاله
معرضه لاختراق جواسيس اجانب لكن مشرعين
جمهوريين اعتبروا ان تحقيق لجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه يهدف الى مضايقه ماسك ويمثل
مثالا على ما يعرف بتسليح الحكومه
الامريكيه ويثير الشك وفق تصريحات خاصه
بنا للسناتور الجمهوري جا شاولي
يبدو انه مستهدف جدا بالنسبه لي اعني ما
يخلقني ان لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه رينو
عن التحقيق وقد تكون على حق بعد ان طالب
كل الديمقراطيين هنا بذلك وبداوا باستخدام
هذه اللغه حول الانتهاكات القانونيه ضد
ماسك اعني ما يدهشني كيف ان بعض زملاء
الديمقراطيين مع احترامي لهم مناهض ون
لحريه التعبير ومن الامور التي يسال
المشرعون الديمقراطيون عنها تقييم
للخصوصيه والامان لخدمه العلامه الزرقاء
وعما اذا كانت تويتر احتفظ ببرنامج شامل
للامن السيبراني لحمايه بيانات المستخدم
منذ استحواذ ماسك عليه حسين الطاوض
العربيه واشنطن لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات